girl named tom
[Applause]
history is made on the voice
as the sibling trio from pettisville
ohio
wins it all well congratulations
we still have glitter in our hair over
here
it's so festive
so festive you all made history tonight
what does this mean to you
wow as the first trio we made history
yeah yeah you're speechless literally
i'm literally speechless i don't know
what to say i mean we're trio we came on
thinking like maybe this will be a flop
you know no one will turn their chairs
for three voices but you know i don't
know i just don't know
odds are against you on the show no no
group's never made it this far yeah
were y'all nervous about auditioning
because of that did you think that you
that's a question i want to know yeah
yeah
josh and i were nervous about
auditioning in general because we're not
sure reality tv was for us
we're like anti that idea but then we
fell in love with it when we got here
yeah and we really were like okay
we want to win this we're doing it yeah
and then you did
hey kelly if you want to add another gig
to your team ichi's always looking okay
okay i'm going through a question now
literally
i'm sorry
well the next question actually goes to
you oh okay two out of the three
finalists we're blake
you etched him out how does that feel
wait what yes two out of the three
finalists were blake's contestants oh oh
they were they were yes i thought you
men are the type five i was like weren't
there five i was like wait um yes no
that was amazing and honestly it doesn't
everybody always says like we brag about
it to be funny but it really is their
talent and honestly this is we were all
talking about it like not only the
coaches but also like me with my like
glam squad and everybody like this has
been the best finale the best season
overall with so much talent and they're
all different like everyone's so
different so it was literally i would
have been happy for anyone that was
gonna win um and it's just they've all
made it to that last show to where you
all get the you know that it's really
capitalizing off this moment afterwards
but i've been telling them since the
blinds about that so well you're at four
wins now he's at nine so you're almost
halfway there to catch it up
percentage-wise
50 of the time that's my batting average
i don't even that's how you do a batting
average but sure i love it we're talking
sports math all of it now how will you
guys celebrate this win
are y'all excited to go home so excited
so excited to go home for the holidays
and be with our family and just
celebrate with everybody who's believed
in us since day one and yeah just spend
that time with us yeah it's really
special to share it with with among the
three of us us um like we were just
holding hands up there like shaking
together i can't imagine being a solo
performer on this show and having to go
through all of that
it's been so special to
be able to celebrate the victories and
yeah together so what comes next then
how do you help navigate navigate
it's a good word how do you help
navigate them into their next steps well
my thing with them and we've been
talking about it especially this morning
a lot um but it was it's more about like
really like it's so important to
surround yourself with such a good team
of good people that you trust and you
want to work with and because that's it
it's like you have the talent you have
the package you write you do all these
things like it's about finding people to
be on your team that believe in you to
get you there and that's a huge thing
that i learned the hard way and had to
like find out you know and so
that's where i would love to help and
i'm already shoot i was like let's get
you on the studio and they're like well
we have a song released tonight and i'm
like wait what
they're releasing a christmas song
tonight no snow for christmas
oh i'm i'm buying it i just found out
about her i already have it honestly
that was such a smart move you know
manifesting your wind almost or just
capitalizing because i've been saying it
doesn't matter if you win or not it's
really about capitalizing on this as an
artist just
this huge fan base all these eyes and
ears are on you you know so regardless
if you're going to win or not it's a
smart move
yeah it's been amazing the outpour of
love from the fans like that's something
that we're going to take with us forever
it's so incredible and congratulations
to you guys last question really quick
y'all performed a jonas brothers song
tonight kelly are you missing nick um no
i told them i was like i have this idea
to do this song with them because i
actually went and saw the jonas brothers
at the bowl like recently so i was like
i was like oh my god that's a fly song i
was like i love that song and so i told
i told them i was like look i love this
song because i just saw them perform it
and i was like i have to do this song
with them and luckily they liked it i
think we i think would have went over
rebecca but the boys were with me
did you tell nick you were performing it
tonight no no i should have i should
have texted him he's of course watching
he's not shame on you
[Music]